now that we've got this pure prototypal
version of the car class let's refactor
it into the very closely related pattern
known as pseudo classical the pattern
were about to build is called pseudo
classical because it attempts to
resemble the class systems from other
languages by adding a thin layer of
syntactic conveniences if we plan on
making a lot of classes in our programs
and we do there's a lot of code here
that would get repetitive to repeat
every time perhaps the language could do
more of these steps automatically
somehow which lines here seem likely to
show up in every class you write and
maybe seem like the language could
provide some mechanism for doing
automatically for you